I don't know Sports um Stephen King okay
she's like what's the sports dog author
the author the slam dunker Steph Curry
[Music]
all right we're gonna play
um do we believe her or not okay okay
there's a female police officer nope
don't believe her
nope
what's the next video damn okay so she
she's in trouble because her husband it
happens to be a drug lord
and she didn't know and she didn't know
what wow Walter White [__] yeah kind of
yeah pretty much it so sucks because but
again like I feel like when I date
people I know like about them like I
know their favorite color and their
blood type you've never been surprised
like you do that wait no no
I was a drug guy like a few months into
our relationship and there were no signs
prior to him telling me there was
definitely sus things like but he told
you though also drug guy and drug lord
or no he was a drug Pusher and then he
went to jail okay Daisy but I remember
oops Daisy
actually this could be true oh I
remember like he'd be like hey I was I
just thought he was cheating and I was
like man this guy sucks dude and he was
like you know all those times I've just
been away I was actually pushing drugs
and I was like okay okay so you're not
cheating on me that's cool yeah yeah
I was actually murdering people oh
you're not cheating on me oh my gosh
baby come here oh I was so worried
around his place it was drug
paraphernalia like weed like so it was
like pushing weed and illegal State like
tie-dye t-shirts yeah and obviously like
cocaine and [__] but there was this one
time he was like would you be mad if I
had to hurt people and I was like yeah
and I what yeah what the [__] and then
he was kind of like but they don't pay
me back
silence and then we continue dating so
all right it was just that okay but I
definitely was like you're reasonable
yeah because then he went to jail he
just got out of jail but I was kind of
like oh that makes sense that makes
sense but I think she wasn't cheating
yeah at least he wasn't no he actually
also was cheating oh okay so he was
selling drugs and cheating [__] you how
was this guy keeping it well listen yeah
he sucks all around damn he does
something so
um the crazy thing is when they search
the home they found like you know the
scales all the stuff to like weigh your
drugs and everything she's like so he's
not a cake baker well that's the thing
is that she thought and he this was one
of his real jobs he was he was a uh a
private Chef for a footballer like a
famous athlete that could be true Okay
cooking up through but yet he was making
a ton more money and not reporting it on
his taxes so then they were that's why
they said there's no way you don't know
because he his tax reports were way off
from what he was spending and their
lifestyle basically yeah it was too rich
was did she become a cop after they got
together I I it doesn't say it doesn't
say when she was a cop but yeah they
don't they don't think so she got fired
but like imagine being like a private
Chef to like like I'm sorry what's an
athlete name Michael Jordan magic Jordan
no Sports
um Stephen King okay Stephen King she's
like what's a sports guy author the
author the slam dunker Steph Curry
Stephen King the murder mystery
basketball player hey yo the guy that
wrote it and scored 36 points in a game
yes well he does it all no imagine being
a chef for that guy that's probably a
lot of money it is yeah I probably would
be like that's a lot Steph Curry is
actually considered a chef boy actually
yeah Steph Curry with the [__] but the
craziest thing about the story is that
uh so they were talking about what he
was using to run his operation have you
guys ever heard of and grow chat no
what's that that was the craziest thing
to me because I read about this thing
called they were like oh he was using
encro chat to do all his deals I was
like the [__] is ankle chat is it like
offer up offer up for drug drug people
this it's this like uh secure phone
that's been modified and it was made by
like criminals it's like an evil
WhatsApp yeah yeah but like you have to
have a certain phone right that does it
and you buy this phone and if you turn
the phone on it'll just go to like a
home screen but if you turn it on a
different way it'll go to the real thing
Black Market Mobile yeah I would be like
are you cheating oh you're just a drug
yeah so then I started diving down that
hole of encro chat and it's it's been
around since like I think 2020 and you
now have the phone don't you know
you would send text messages and it
would delete in 30 seconds like and I
would always be like I'd be like man
this guy is cheating on me also I was
right he was but also he was doing drugs
[__] you [__] you yeah so the cat the
camera doesn't work all the other stuff
is fake the GPS doesn't work all that
stuff is like in it it uh encrypts all
your messages but also you have to
subscribe to the service and there's
like I think there's they said there's
60 000 subscribers and it's been it's
since been like deep they don't have SIM
cards they have SIM cards oh it's like
when a homie has like telegram it's like
what's [__]
for sure for drugs I have a telegram or
if they have truth
what's this today what it's like when
they're on like signal Telegram and
WhatsApp like why like you are up to
something kind of naughty yeah why is
she hot she was like the sexiest officer
I want to see she's like sexy as [__]
bro she knows yeah damn she helps is
this in London or like UK oh she does I
could tell by the checkered [__]
neckties yeah yeah a constable stuff I
could tell by the [__] eye makeup
this is my husband's a drug lord hella
heavy on the bottom too oh yeah it's
like the daily stars all right let's do
the Sun what did they say you dated a
drug lord I should give him that that
story I should actually like push that
publication but yeah this ankro chat
thing is crazy because uh so they said
they did a it's been stung already like
they've the cops got through it and they
discontinued it but they said they found
that 90 of the users on there were
criminals yeah and they've never even
heard of so what's the other 10 doing
cheaters cheaters people that never got
a chance to do the moderators
probably like FBI agents looking for
like 100 right yeah yeah but I never
knew that that was a [__] thing
that's [__] cool anchor chat and this
is like an encro chat commercial like I
know good thing it's discontinued in a
way right hey go chat damn yeah so if
you guys ever were curious if something
like that was a thing it is because ever
since it's been defunct there's other
ones that took its place
Synchro chat right I miss crime
sometimes you miss your life of crime
yeah you're a criminal boy because like
every day was exciting yeah do you miss
your crime life I like the creativity
behind it you were a crime boy
um silly yeah silly boy silly crime yeah
but I do remember like like hating uh
you just have like bright ideas and then
you and your execute execute it that's
what I missed I miss having a group of
friends
see that so we were like she was like oh
look up on that Bible they did some
stories about me here's one about Kazumi
oh my God while driving can't be fun
she's revealed how she's making the
money back can't sit down after spending
14k on bum has no regrets that's so
funny good for a year bro I really did
and I don't know how to drive 14 000 on
a bum it was fourteen thousand it was
25k but I don't know the conversion also
it's unrelated yeah I don't know how to
drive but that doesn't mean anything oh
they were like she had nothing to do
with it do you Uber everywhere yes I do
so what did you do get those hemorrhoid
seats to sit down on when you go over no
I had like this like those questions
that would like make me really high I
like the neck pillow yeah yeah like a
Boppy Pillow but like for like BBL you
would bring that with you like
everywhere I wouldn't even have I would
only have doggy
doggy like I wouldn't and if I were to
have
me like floating up it looks like a
ritual up here
how long did you have to do that I did
it for a year because I'm just a weird
girl oh yeah
you like to you just didn't want to like
feel like yeah there's it's like I was
gonna pop or something I just was so
cool a blow up doll for oh yeah what is
the worst that could happen at the time
I didn't know how to work out yeah I was
searching for like my personal trainer
and like I just feared like because
there's you you couldn't get your old
body back like that like you could like
eat [__] not work out and then your body
is back to being ass and I was like this
[__] was so expensive it hurt it was so
time consuming I want to make sure I
preserve it as long as possible until I
find out how to actually maintain this
ass so once I found a personal trainer
that taught me how to be a Fitbit I was
like now I can sit it I don't know why
it took me a year it took me a while how
long would it would it usually been like
if they were like the doctors like are
after a month you can sit after like
probably three months oh wow you really
win sit after a week or so but it's like
those are the people who have very like
their their asses are either so fat it
wouldn't matter if it went down or they
just like like looked Supernatural
anyways so it wouldn't have mattered but
some girls like woke up with like size
large asses and I got a size medium like
what what the [__] was that so they so
there's they plump up sometimes the
there's yeah like some butts will get
bigger it's kind of like a crap shoot of
what type of butt cheek it just depends
on your own genetics yeah and also just
kind of like his style like his like
little his style is like like a slow
kind of situation but like he gave some
girls like booties like oh and that's
what you wanted that looks pretty
natural you know yeah imagine if my butt
was like that yeah no that wouldn't look
right now you want to see it from the
front I want to see it like yeah oh you
want more maybe a little more nah that's
perfect yo I would not mess with I mean
that's you that's on you but like do a
little edit I would have to gain more
weight because we have to put fat right
okay and then and then when you gain
weight it won't be proportionate like
obviously the Lipo is here but I would
probably gain weight in my arms in my
face and then it wouldn't look good you
also have to change your diet and like
do it all legit yeah yeah like so did
you get with like a nutrition I just get
a meal prep but mostly I just like eat
bulge shoot and then like go to my
trainer and cook that's nice dude
just eat [__]
[Music]
foreign